- There was a good period of time
where confident, talented, powerful men
walked around with curly hair.
And we're gonna bring it back.
(upbeat jazz music)
The male perm was popular
like in the 70's and the 80's
and it's about to become
super popular in 2015.
- I'm a big K-pop fan.
A lot of those guys, they get perms.
- If a friend asks you
to do something you do it
but the male perm, it's not here to stay.
- The male perm is coming back.
- The steps in getting a perm are,
we would first shampoo
the hair and get it clean.
And then we would set the hair in rollers
and then we would determine
whether we would just
set it going back or spiral perm.
- When I saw my Aunt Doris get her perm,
I said to myself, one day
I wanna grow up (laughs)
and get my Aunt Doris' haircut.
- [Voiceover] How's it look?
- [Voiceover] I mean... (laughs)
- I feel like a badass.
- [Voiceover] You look like a badass.
- (laughs) Thanks.
- And then we would
apply the perm solution
and we would let that sit in.
And the perm solution is the acid
and then we would be using the alkaline
which is the neutralizer,
which will neutralize it
and bring the pH back in the hair.
(upbeat jazz music)
- [Voiceover] Here you go.
- Alright can I open?
- Open!
- Oh my God (laughs).
- Surprise!
- (laughs) Nope.
- When should I open my eyes (laughs).
- Now.
- Oh my God! (laughs)
Why does it look like
I'm a 55 year old man.
- I'm gonna bring this back.
- [Voiceover] People will love it.
- We're gonna go crash this party
and see what people think of our perms.
(crowd talking and laughing)
- Yeah!!
- They're bringing the male perm back.
- I like your perm the best.
- [Voiceover[ It's most natural.
- It feels like you
didn't even get a perm.
- [Voiceover] It feels
like you're what Fabio
should have been.
- Male perm!
- I'm getting a perm right now.
- The male perm is back.
- Male perm!
- The male perm is back!
(funky jazz music)